you start reacting to the Kevin Samuel's  ship but then when you start to decide  to do your own show well it was in I had  a boyfriend before and we broke up and  like  December it's like February I don't  remember when but I was really sad and  so I was like I'll just do a show and we  can talk about relationships because the  cool thing about London was  you can meet people from like every Walk  of Life and from everywhere so I can  meet someone from Italy and from Spain  and from I could have a girl in my  basketball team that's like that's from  London from London I could meet everyone  and the cultures will be really really  different and I just thought that was so  cool I'd never lived anywhere that was  like that diverse you know so  um  February 27th was my first show so I'm  almost at a year and yeah basically  um I just thought we could come in and  talk about something that everyone has  in common which is relationships